so no Gallagher thanks for talking to us
on Sky News here on tour yes happy
coincidence that Englander here at same
time meticulously meticulously planned
over the last eight months fans I gather
as some of them came along to watch you
were they behaving themselves
yeah there were Swedish fans there the
other night and even a few locals and
some English friends and it was great
there was you know there was a bit of
mild butter and all that as there is at
these things but it was all right there
was there was no there's no great drama
it's got to make of the low turnout of
England fans compared to the Swedish
turnout
um says everything about both economies
I would've thought quite difficult to
get here but um I just rare to come to a
tournament and see it as little of an
English presence don't I see Ukraine's
nearer to Sweden because it must be I
think all all Sweden's games are in Kiev
so maybe that makes a difference oh yeah
I guess yeah yeah they are based here
there is a lot of them around they're
behaving themselves though but I'm yeah
it's over to the last three euros and
their England is usually kind of swamped
the place but um it makes a nice change
so it can be quite intense with lots of
England fans because we've that causing
lots of police and we've that caused
lots of you know tension so uh but it's
nice it's quite calm as you can see
Swedish found said to me down in the
founders only he thought was
disappointing there weren't more England
fans and he asked me why don't why
doesn't your country like its team do
you think that's true no no I mean it's
you know it's kind of this took place to
cot Minami
to travel all across like you say to be
based in one city is is as expensive
enough to try and get around I think
actually England progress through the
tournament you see more and more I guess
bad headlines before it even kicked off
have you seen any of that yourself
what's the sort of atmosphere that you
experience I have seen nothing at all
not even seen a great deal of police
presence I've been out and about and we
were out a couple of nights ago run all
the bars and it was fine well actually
it was very very pleasant but um we not
sought the eat English press they like
to do that kind of thing that they do
not I mean the truth is always very very
very different but um I've not seen any
any of the you know manifestations of
any of the scare stories at all it's
been quite opposite I think and what did
you make of the British government's
decision to boycott this tournament over
Tymoshenko the opposition leader who's
in jails at the right move basically
they've said we don't like the way you
run it in Ukraine you're a bit corrupt
so we're not coming I mean does that
should it mix in that way politics and
spoil you know I think is that the pot
calling the kettle black
okay I don't know about to the football
tonight what do you reckon prediction
England I've been beating this lot for
about ten years so it would be I think
you'll have to win because England don't
want to be going the face of Ukraine
they might need it might need a point on
the last night that would be that would
give them a mountain to climb but I
think if England score first will win we
got behind you could see England
struggling but I'm gonna go for it how
important is this not just in terms of
boosting England within the group well I
mean if we're not if we don't win this
you probably say we're out you know if
we do win it we could England could go
on and get a favorable draw entirely
unlikely they're gonna get favorable
draw but they could get a fable draw in
the next round and maybe get to the
semi-finals you never know but it is
what's great about the euros as opposed
to the World Cup there are big games in
the eurozone oddly rarely the all the
games are important ways in the World
Cup we take two maybe a week or ten days
to get going you've got the ground
running there which it's a more
difficult tournament to win but if they
win and win well you know you could see
them going on and stringing a few
results together boy you just don't know
with it maybe what do they need to do
tonight please go first yeah our goalie
he'll look after after that what about
Roy Hodgson is he gonna be a hero or a
villain at the end of this tournament I
don't think it's gonna be either you
know I don't I think as football
supporters we're all aware that in
another got a great squad we are you
know we haven't got the year when we had
six or seven great great players they're
all kind of coming to the end of their
career now so maybe only got two or
three so I don't think really anybody's
gonna be blaming odds in if it if we
don't you know get to the court files or
anything
he's not had a great deal of time to
work with the players the the tests are
coming the next World Cup and that's
gonna be difficult enough playing in
Brazil because you're into Brazil well
it seems like quite a party down here I
mean the atmosphere is good and those
who have come seem to be enjoying it
I've got to say I've been very very
impressed with it's a beautiful place
the weather's been great it's been great
like I said it was we were out the other
night so I was in the morning it was no
trouble at all no I'd get sore but you
know I guess you get probably quite a
bit of attention from the England fans
how do you deal with that I do get a bit
of mind that I don't mind but my
security got there he's on the verge of
a nervous breakdown look at him there
he's only 17 look yeah his work got cut
out for him but it can't be a bit come
they can't get the longer the night goes
on the drunker people get it the camera
it get a bit irrational you just gotta
pick and choose where you go and that I
never really have that much trouble do
not mean boisterous novices what about
England fans in general these days I
mean it's different from years gone by
obviously but do they represent England
well I think so I mean I've been to the
last three tournaments and it kind of
get a bit tricky with your with a lot of
England France because for right or
wrong or for whatever reason they do it
England's do attract a lot of police and
that brings tensions you know I mean but
I've been with groups of England fan
Mizzou who are treated badly by police
for no reason just because they
funds but then I've been caught with
mobs of England fans really not the kind
of people you want to get involved in
tonight I mean so but I guess it's like
that with everywhere I mean the the
whole of Europe is always down on
England about Iligan ISM and all that
what they've got it you know the doctor
no better near the poles
I mean Russians are making that headline
so everybody can as their moments do not
I mean so but I think generally England
fans represent England well in their
numbers I think I mean the spectacle at
the rings of the tournaments you know
we're not the Irish nobody that would be
as great fans of scotch or the Irish but
don't give anybody a run for their money
what about Ukraine next do they are
worried they've got the home crowds
behind me totally home teams of the home
stadium always not to play any of them
and although I'm not sure how great
great a team they are but England
certainly don't want to be going there
and looking for a win you know added to
that we will have Rouen about what I
can't don't really going that one is a
win to nil or one nil even and hanging
on wood you know $50,000 slot breathing
down your neck be a great game though
tonight
the Swedish fans outnumber English fans
are you going to be in fine voice trying
to match them me no I shall be sipping
champagne in some corporate box with the
real fans keep it real no thanks very
much thank you